[Musique]
aux etats unis près de cinq jours après
l'attentât qui a endeuillé les jeux
olympiques d'atlanta
les enquêteurs du fbi a eu manifestement
sous pression pour aboutir avant la fin
de ces jeux affirme tenir plusieurs
bonnes pistes la principale étant
semble-t-il richard jewel un ancien
policier de 33 ans qui est devenue la
personne la plus épié des états unis
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux tiret
kurt est clos par nier
richard jewel est chez lui l'amérique
entière le sait des agents du fbi qui
ont perquisitionné son domicile ont dîné
hier au soir
selon cnn ils ont commandé 20 pizza
depuis dix jours toutes les caméras
américaines sont pointés vers atlanta
désormais l'homme le plus connu de ces
jeux est un simple agent de sécurité à
la radio dans la rue des boîtes
commencent à s'élever pour dire que
décidément trop c'est trop on sait tout
de lui de son passé on y trouve qu'il
ait l'air d'un ancien policier courtrai
qui est allé d'échec en échec son ancien
supérieur va même jusqu'à nous
distribuer son dossier personnel
on y découvre qu'il a démissionné après
avoir embouti deux voitures de police
son chef peut alors le transformer en
gardiens de prison lui va préféré
démissionner compte tenu de ce qui s'est
passé avec les véhicules de patrouille
oui on a fait en sorte les menuiseries
toucher aux voitures avait il le droit
d'avoir une arme en tant que gardien de
prison
les armes ce n'était pas le problème
mais je ne crois pas qu'il ait gardé en
prison
héros ou criminelles pour l'instant les
charretiers well le 7 mai en voulant
médiatiser son rôle on a permis aux
télévisions américaines de faire de son
histoire un véritable feuilleton même
innocent il n'aura plus qu'à quitter la
ville
[Musique]